alle spieler die in dieser runde sind
werden einfach gebannt alle ausnahmslos
alle herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge publikum heute ist einer der dabei
war er einmal ausgesetzt und heute bevor
wir loslegen denn heute natürlich auch
wieder eine change am start
und zwar ich weiß gar nicht mehr von
welchen zuschauer die kamen ihr
kommentar falls ist deine ist schreibt
morton rein hab ich mir aufgeschrieben
und zwar die hater challenge heißt wir
müssen in dieser runde einfach die ganze
zeit abtreten und safe kriegen wir hin
chat band und ich fange jetzt einfach
mal an und sagt ich hasse euch alle
mithelfen
der körper war instance und fresse dafür
so hat eben nicht ein bisschen in der
lobby rum gesammelt und damals schon
supporter zu mir so patrick schreiben
ist verboten das ist doof und was er für
die suche gemacht werde schreibt
vielleicht ja geschrieben
dieses modul sagt mehr als eure mütter
der boni werden die chat bands verteilt
leute ich hoffe ihr wisst es zu schätzen
irgendwie das geht unser leben hier sehr
schwer einzuschätzen ist das einfach mal
350 ha ha ha
die unterste aussage ich bringe aber
seit wochen fast nur noch die ampel
league wenn es um minecraft geht und
liebe diesen modus einfach zu hause
wir brauchen eine gebrauch irgendwas was
richtig schwierig ist dass die runde so
richtig schwer macht hallo ich will auch
die leute nicht so kasper leine wie kann
man helfen um leute zu beleidigen
weil jesus wtf
selber hdm adm ist auch classic es kurz
zu sagen hat die app steht hdm denn fit
multi geil ist moore alter darf man auch
dass man auch sexuell belästigen
ja ok aber ich würde sowas von gebannt
hierfür wo die nazis in der runde
alte und die nazis ist voll mit mit
ihrem einspruch geklaut ich würde sagen
im bett frag deine mama und jetzt genau
das geschrieben als ob jetzt alle somit
hätten die hedge es geht um leute die
hätten change geht um alle machen mit
es ist spaß für die ganze familie ohne
witz geht einfach auf dem zeitpunkt
play.com und in der wohnung
quartierverein wickrath leute wenn dass
irgendeiner von permanenten server team
sieht leute heute ist eine ausnahme
das ist karneval müssen ist es gerade
weise der insider informieren weil eines
tages sogar mit dem traktor
ja wir sind tatsächlich richtiger
landeier würde man gar nicht denken mit
dem traktor irgendwo angefahren und wo
man eigentlich lang fahren durfte wenn
man nicht so scheiße man was machen wir
wenn sie wollen kommen oder walter marx
so wir sagen einfach es karneval
wir sagen einfach wir dachten es kann
halt unter dem ist immer so mein alter
ich habe jemanden umgebracht
was mache ich denn man sagt doch einfach
du hast gedacht dass wir keine wahl
ach so ja klar wir dürfen also live
hacks sollte ronaldo online jetzt ja
wohl das b modou geschafft meine größte
angst dieses verhalten hat wir müssen
wir hätten hatte die nasa dieses ist
völlig richtig großer gibt über glaube
ich einfach so echt ja ich glaube schon
dass safe on youtube
der name sagt mir was ich hatte damit
mit zombies zu tun für mich ganz sicher
alter wie die ausrasten
das schreiben maria wurde von dem
römischen soldaten vergewaltigt was ist
los mit der wunde kranke weltall
maria ist einem okay also im es wissen
mang ist max und ich bin ich bin werde
ich finde ich übrigens gleich manager
sales team deathmatch a4 fall
weiterhelfen hatte junge ich würde hier
nach dieser runde leute wird einfach
alle spieler die in dieser runde sind
werden einfach gebannt alle ausnahmslos
alle jetzt schwer zu finden weiß ich
finde ich schön finde schön wenn ich in
den nächsten fünf sekunden finnische
dann habt ihr alle hinter mir
wir müssen auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen mehr hätten fragt da kommt
einfach jesus von hinten
was ist los man was ist mit jesus durch
jesus töten wenn jesus töten habe ich
habe jesus getötet so wartet der seiner
ohne beißen candy und weißen kennen oder
war schon wieder jesus aber ich muss
etwas erholen da müsste ich hab keine
pfeile und als er weg jetzt schaffen wir
jesus beleidigend über fleißig weiter
ich finde ich versuche ihr paket zu
machen oder was ja man jesus traf mich
an ich denke ich schwöre ich töte jetzt
wirklich jesus jesus alle drei desto
passt laut neid ich will jetzt nicht wo
jesus hat historisch korrekten und ich
habe mir fest wir müssen mehr hätten
leute schreibt mal in die kommentare
auch bedenkt dass wir bis jetzt genug
geredet haben in dieser rolle mit der
hitachi heraus du bist raus haben mord
getötet
ihr kann so ja ich kann die newcomerin
ab nein ich habe sharp ist ein schwert
ich weg alles jetzt kein mensch hat eine
chance genau dass politik und ins
intranet weg von oak ridge racer ist da
und so als ob sowie der frist meine
frist so krass ist mit dreieinhalb
herzen abgezogen waren
was war das doch mein dick ist op-trakt
komm runter adhs kind verstehe man muss
es aussehen für die person
trotzdem hat jeder hin und her und die
asche und spd spricht also für mich holt
apple oder man ich dachte diese channel
irgendwie cooler und nicht so einfach so
krass respekt beleidigen aber jetzt erst
zum beispiel kate aber eher report mich
hat auch save
wir müssen es am ende auf wenn es am
ende auf lösen
ob er kenne keine tiere kamen okay okay
er brack kann man kann man auch banken
okay aber ich habe ja verbrennt er
brennt brennt hat eine freileitung
nachteile
ich glaub nicht ich glaube ich ins koma
und sos dein alter nice
jetzt laufen ist direkt im minus bei
jungen ist es halt noch richtig intense
ist richtig intense hatte das ok es hat
echt so als ich habe ein bisschen
besseres schwert aber das hat auch lucky
ok 60 sekunden und gewinnen mehr drin 60
und mittels fracking tracking
sie sollten das gerade auflösen man
sollte nicht noch weiter machen mit der
scheiße
bitte bitte